here with a message
to Angelina Jolie,
our benefactor this week,
Donald Trump.
(fanfare playing)
(cheers and applause)
-Hi, Chuck. How are you?
-You know my name is Chris.
-Wonderful.
-(laughter)
-(soft music playing)
-First of all, Angelina,
I know what
you're going through.
Divorce is the best.
It's a lot, a lot,
a lot, a lot of fun.
-(laughter)
-I've been through several.
And let me tell you,
they go by so fast,
-so savor every moment.
-(laughter)
-And can I say something, Chuck?
-Well, you're already talking.
-Can I? Can I say something?
-Yeah, you are talking already.
I'm glad
that you've finally done
what all of America
has been wanting for years
and dumped that scruffy
pretty boy loser.
Honestly, his movies
are absolute garbage.
Although, I did have a few
laughs during 12 Years a Slave.
-(audience groaning)
-Well, that's not a...
-That's a terrible thing to say.
-So much fun. So much fun.
-It's not fun at all.
-TRUMP: So much fun, Chuck.
-It was not fun at all!
-So much fun, Chuck.
And let me tell you,
the timing is perfect
because I am about ready to get
a new wife, and it could be you.
-(laughter) -I mean,
what have you got to lose?
What are you talk...?
You're married!
-Hey, have you seen Melania?
-Yes! She's beautiful!
Have you seen...? No,
she's a complete and total mess.
-I don't... -Okay? I already?
-(audience groaning)
-These people are horrified.
-TRUMP: They love me.
Are you kidding me?
I wear my mother's pearls
as a (bleep) ring.
(laughter)
Imagine, imagine
a luxurious life as first lady,
constantly making love to me.
And I'm a human pile
of candy corn,
melting on the dash
of a dump truck.
(laughter)
And I'd do you right.
I'd do you right.
Angelina, I promise,
I'd love your international
group of babies
like they were my own.
-My own little bowl of Skittles.
-(laughter and groaning)
Just think of the things
I could get away with
if I was surrounded
by your little
community college catalogue
-of multicultural bonbons.
-(laughter)
Angelina, let's make marriage
great again!